est-ce que tu prends mon dieu oui depuis
toujours
non depuis qu'on sait que je prends
c'est arrivé quand subitement qu'en
quelques années le cas l'occasion je
vais un peu du jour
tout à coup j'ai eu la certitude que
c'était vrai mais que c'était le même
dieu pour tout le monde je suis des
listes puisque la série n'était pas
spécialement de catholiques
non pour moi c'est que même dieu pour
tout le monde tu crois que tu vas au
paradis ou en enfer
je crois que je vais revenir à coup sûr
terre sais pas j'ai pas fini de rire je
parle j'ai pas là j'ai pas eu le temps
de tout faire je peux avoir le temps de
tout faire
chacun d'eux chose que je veux faire et
je vais encore venir un coup franc situé
en vendée sur terre qu'est ce que tu
aurais envie de faire que tu n'es pas
fait une école j'aimerais beaucoup créé
une vraie école et vous l'école dans les
enfants aux reines et l'école que j'ai
détesté mois apprend des choses à des
enfants c'est ce qu'a de mieux parce que
si tu fais des enfants heureux et
intelligent ça fera des adultes heureux
et intelligent et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de linars dit tu es abonné
vous y mettez un peu de bleu